(Luwin): Robert Baratheon's victory
at the Trident
was a turning point
in the war for the Iron Throne.
While it was clear the gods
were smiling on the rebel forces,
Aerys Targaryen still held
the Red Keep at King's Landing.
As Robert was wounded and unable to ride,
it was up to Eddard Stark
to make for the capital
and force the Mad King
to give up the throne.
Lord Stark reached the city gates
to find that Tywin Lannister,
Lord of Casterly Rock,
had already sacked the city
in Robert's name.
House Lannister had remained neutral
up to this point,
ignoring requests for help
from both the crown and the rebels.
Now that Robert's eventual victory
was assured,
it seemed Lord Tywin
had finally chosen a side.
Lord Eddard was horrified by
what he saw when he entered the city -
homes looted and burned,
women raped,
scores of innocent citizens killed.
Disgusted, he led his force
up Visenya's hill to the Red Keep.
Upon entering the throne room,
he found King Aerys
lying in a pool of blood...
dead, by the hand of
his own sworn Kingsguard,
Jaime Lannister,
who sat brazenly upon the throne.
Demanding to know
the whereabouts of Queen Rhaella,
Lord Eddard was informed
the queen and her son Viserys
had been spirited away to Dragonstone
before the Lannisters arrived.
But other members of the royal family
were not as fortunate.
Elia Martell of Dorne,
who was the wife of Prince Rhaegar,
had been raped and murdered
by Ser Gregor Clegane
on Lord Tywin's orders.
Ser Gregor and his men had also
butchered Rhaegar's young children.
When Robert was well enough
to reach the capital,
Lord Eddard demanded the Lannisters
answer for their heinous crimes.
Robert refused,
and sent himself to relieve
the Baratheon stronghold of Storm's End,
which was still under siege
by forces loyal to the crown.
Whatever words passed between
the two old friends are known only to them,
but Lord Eddard is said
to have left King's Landing in anger.
Later, when Robert was crowned,
he appointed Jon Arryn
as Hand of the King.
Lord Arryn's first order of business
was to broker a truce
with the Martells of Dorne,
who were outraged by the brutal murder
of Princess Elia and her children.
Following the death of Lyanna Stark,
who had been betrothed to Robert,
Houses Baratheon and Lannister
were joined in marriage
when the new king took
Tywin Lannister's eldest daughter, Cersei,
as his queen.
As for Eddard Stark, he returned
to his stronghold of Winterfell,
forever haunted by his sister's death,
and the shameful way
that Robert had secured his throne.